[Music]
it's go time I am pooped sorry Big Bang
fans CBS just announced this coming
season will be the last four TVs number
one comedy I'm sorry Sheldon but this
sort of thing happens the emmy-winning
show will end its run in May of 2019
earlier this year the stars told us they
weren't sure if the show would continue
past season 12 you know I'm waiting for
this conversation
I feel super grateful that was possible
so who knows what the future holds
today Kaylie posted drowning in tears we
promise to bring you the best season yet
up next the cast of this is us sits down
for a legendary photo shoot for season
three mom and dad are with their grown
children
they're obviously existing in different
eras but it was it was sort of a
bucket-list thing that's for sure what
makes this photo shoot extra special its
famed photographer Annie Leibovitz
behind the camera it's nice when a
legendary photographer is now working
with us over here so we're all very
excited working was such a famous person
made Chrissy a little star-struck
I'm like okay you know cuz it's such a
special it's such a special moment and
another TV news Milly Bobby Brown
celebrated stranger things 12 Emmy
nominations at a New York Netflix event
the 14 year old also earned her second
nomination you know you just stick to
the same things to same friends same
people same bedsheets well that we're
not doing diamonds up in this but Miele
has one famous new friend she recently
hung out with Taylor Swift backstage at
a concert
I kind of had like a a moment but yeah
she's amazing and I met her cat
[Music]